les enfants de la République Frédéric
Haziza Frédéric
Haziza Frédéric Aziza radiologie
bonjour et bienvenue dans les enfants de
la République dont vous êtes l'invité
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes né en
1989 à Romorantin précisément c'est
votre anniversaire c'était votre
anniversaire il y a quelques jours le 16
mars 1989 donc Romorantin dans le
Loir-et-Cher de parents marocains
naturalisé français permet de anesthésie
ces mères chefs d'entreprises dans la
restauration vous passez ensuite votre
enfance à Casablanca avant de revenir en
France vous faites vos études de droit à
Nantes ou vous militez ensuite en
politique d'abord à l'UMP et pour
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 avant de
rejoindre le modem de François Bayrou en
2014 et aussi de vous engager dans le
syndicalisme au sein de la CFTC point
d'orgue de votre engagement politique
vous êtes élu député MoDem de
Loire-Atlantique en 2017 et réélu en
2022 entre-temps vous êtes devenus en
2020 secrétaire d'État chargé de la
jeunesse puis reconduite à ce poste en
juillet 2022 alors est juste de dire ça
et la Eric ce parcours que votre
parcours fait de vous et bien une offre
de la République une enfant de la
République a eu la chance d'avoir
beaucoup d'amour dans sa famille et dans
le fond moi mon parcours c'est celui de
l'école de l'engagement associatif qui
m'a fait grandir et des rencontres des
rencontres qu'elles soient
syndicales politiques des rencontres sur
sur les marchés oui c'est le rêve
français et j'ai eu le j'en ai j'en fais
un petit bout le vrai français le modèle
français les deux alors né en France
vous êtes donc grandi à Casablanca au
Maroc qu'est-ce que vous retenez de
cette enfance marocaine sera à l'aéri
beaucoup de richesses beaucoup de
beaucoup de souvenirs des souvenirs
d'une famille particulièrement joyeuse
où on aime on aime vivre ensemble ou les
générations s'entremêlent ou les la
culture est présente la culture pour le
coup marocaine mais aussi les fois et
dans le fond ce que je retiens c'est
beaucoup de soleil beaucoup de rires
beaucoup de beaucoup de journées à
partager exactement une culture
particulièrement méditerranéenne avec
beaucoup de liens beaucoup de liens
beaucoup de lait parce que si le Maroc
est une famille qui ont été pour vous
une sorte de on va dire made in pot
culturel et communautaire vous savez moi
j'ai eu la chance de grandir dans une
famille recomposée alors comme des
millions de Français mes parents ont
divorcés très jeunes et 4-5 ans j'ai une
famille recomposée avec un beau-père
italien sarde méditerranéen qui est un
amoureux du Maroc
il s'est il s'est remis en couple avec
avec ma mère et il avait eu des enfants
d'une première d'une première couche
beaucoup plus âgée que nous et qui dans
le fond ont composé cette grande famille
passer de deux à plus de 5 6 ça permet
aussi d'apprendre de l'autre de partager
et je crois que c'est ce que je retiens
le plus avec une particularité de cette
famille recomposée
vos frères et soeurs sont aussi quelque
part un peu Juifs exactement il se
trouve que la première couche de mon de
mon beau-père c'était c'était une une
juive marocaine et et dont les enfants
donc avec les trois premiers enfants
c'est farad et ensuite il y a eu un
troisième Julio pour le coup avec son
autre notre compagne et puis il y avait
nous moi et mon frère et donc dans le
fond cette famille était était au
confessions différentes mais dans le
fond avec beaucoup de commun et ce
commun c'est le goût du partage la
présence des grands-parents la présence
des voisins des amis et dans le fond le
goût de l'engagement parce que on venait
on venait peut-être de confessions
différentes mais fondamentalement notre
famille elle regarde ce qui nous
unissent qui nous réunit et c'est
valeurs communes et donc il y avait
beaucoup de respect du respect de la
pratique ou de l'absence de pratique le
respect des temps et des uns des autres
et des générations la culture séfarade
ça parle pour vous c'est
c'est beaucoup de fêtes c'est beaucoup
de partage c'est c'est un petit bout un
petit bout de soleil parce que chez vous
il y avait l'Aïd il y avait le Ramadan
il y avait shabbat la Mimouna et les
autres faits et
on fêtait effectivement le début du
ramadan ou encore ou encore les mimounas
ou les chabads dans le fond on était
dans un moment de partage de la foi ou
de la pratique de l'autre de la fête de
l'autre et surtout beaucoup de respect
et c'était juste ça c'est-à-dire que tu
pouvais faire ou ne pas faire mais dans
le fond et bien tu partages tu partages
et tu célébrais et c'est beaucoup
d'unités que ça crée et c'est ça qui
compte et c'est ça c'est comme ça que
j'ai grandi j'ai grandi dans cette
diversité mais dans le respect des des
cultures et des liens c'est en vous
cette
héritage marocain Italo séfarade
profondément je suis profond mais vous
savez c'est héritage les profondément
français parce que si un pays dans
lequel et bien on est nourri de ses
racines dans lequel les les différences
sont des richesses parce qu'il y a un
commun parce qu'il y a des valeurs et
parce qu'il y a un socle c'est la France
et donc cette France elle rayonne elle
rayonne par son universalisme ça veut
dire que dans le fond tu peux être à
l'autre bout du monde avoir un cœur
français et aussi beaucoup de souvenirs
beaucoup de beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de
cultures locales qui est partagée et ça
c'est profondément français profondément
français alors justement cette culture
française c'est de culture séparate
cette culture marocaine qui sont en vous
c'est ce qui vous a conduit à être à
l'écoute de l'autre à l'écoute des
autres et à construire et à construire
des liens la force je crois de notre
pays mais aussi la force de l'éducation
de mes parents c'était de jamais se
résigner de faire confiance de de
finalement permettre que ce soit aux
employés qu'ils ont pu embaucher que ce
soit dans le cadre des caravanes mais on
a fait beaucoup de caravanes médicales
avec avec pour le coup mon père ou ou
des actions associatives autour de
l'école avec ma mère ce qu'elle nous a
transmis ce qu'ils nous ont transmis
c'est le fait de s'arrêter et d'être
dans l'action prendre le temps d'être
dans l'action parce que on grandit parce
qu'on se nourrit parce que on est fier
de ce qu'on aime quand on les voit agir
agir contre une inégalité ou une
injustice mais aussi à jour pour quelque
chose qui nous paraît important et le
lien le respect de l'autre la
construction à cloud tendre la main
c'est quelque chose dans laquelle bien
j'ai grandi et je crois que c'est
l'héritage aussi de mes grands-parents
vous avez grandi avec on va dire un
drame de votre vie votre enfance
marocaine a été stoppé net par un
attentat qui a visé le Positano le
restaurant de vos parents c'était le 16
le 16 mai 2003 à Casablanca vendredi
soir on avait parfois malheureusement
des des moments trop traumatiques
effectivement c'était ça a été un
attentat quand tu as 14 ans tu te dis
pas que c'est possible mais la folie la
folie d'homme qui les amène sur le
chemin du terrorisme qui t'apprendre la
vie d'autre amène au pire c'est
mortifère ce sont des ce sont le c'est
le fruit d'idéologie et dans le fond la
réaction de de ma famille et celle de ma
mère en particulier a été bien de
prendre parfois prendre la route pour la
route mais on va préciser les choses on
va rappeler cette journée cette soirée
du 16 mai 2003 une série de cinq
attentats pour la plupart des attaques
Sud donc dans celui qui a visé le
restaurant de vos parents qui a fait 41
morts une centaine de avec notamment
mobile antisémite oui il se trouve que
il y avait il y avait un mobile
antisémite c'était du terrorisme
islamiste et il lui disait notre
restaurant parmi les autres qui ont été
visés parce que nous avions des associés
des associés juifs marocains pour le
coup c'était c'est parti de la famille
c'est des amis de la famille et je crois
que ce modèle finalement de culture qui
qui célèbre qui s'unissent qui regarde
pas leurs différences qui qui qui vivent
dans le fond simplement mais qui
partagent et bien déplaisait des
plaisait et pour le coup le Royaume du
Maroc à l'époque avait réagi de manière
particulièrement ferme et exactement et
parfois vraiment très offensive pour
réapaiser mais aussi pour appeler que
dans au sein du Royaume du Maroc les la
sécurité la paix était un droit quel que
soit sa confession et il a lutté il a
lutté fermement contre l'islamisme
terroriste je suppose que c'est attentat
vous aviez 14 ans à l'époque ça vous a
marqué ça vous marque encore oui bien
sûr ça que ça marque d'autant plus que
le terrorisme aujourd'hui il touche
plein de pays quel que soit d'ailleurs
la situation du pays
il touche tout le monde il touche qu'on
soit aisé ou un peu moins aisé il touche
qu'on est une fois qu'on la pratique ou
pas il touche des pays laïques ils nous
touchent nous dans notre quotidien mais
surtout il nous oblige
il touche en premier lieu les musulmans
d'abord les pays musulmans
je pense évidemment au Maroc mais on
sait que les attentats se démultiplient
c'est là où c'est très différent de la
religion ce sont c'est un mouvement
idéologique c'est un c'est c'est du
terrorisme ce sont des extrémistes et
dans le fond ces extrémistes ils peuvent
être de plusieurs fois mais le plus dur
le plus important c'est de bâtir de
l'unité de la cohésion et pour ça il
faut créer des moments durant contre du
lien et cette unité là on doit on doit
la construire et la bâtir dans notre
pays il faut éclairer les esprits pour
pas les laisser se prendre alors ce
jour-là votre mère elle décide de
prendre la voiture avec vous de frères
et elle fait ce jour-là cette nuit là
Casablanca Thionville en voiture je
n'oublierai pas ce jour parce qu'il se
trouve que je me souviens de cette
voiture c'est une Renault 19 dorée ça
veut dire que je me souviens de cette
voiture donc on n'est pas grand chose
dedans on avait principalement nos amis
et maman comme je pense beaucoup de
mamans ou beaucoup de parents souhaitent
se mettre nous mettre en situation de
voilà de de sécurité de confort alors
même que c'est très bousculant c'est
c'est ce sont des drames et
cette nuit-là nous avons perdu des amis
beaucoup d'amis de mes parents elle
prend la route elle traverse le Maroc
jusqu'à Tanger puis un petit bout de
l'Espagne et puis on prend le on prend
le bateau de 7 pour arriver de Tanger
pour arriver à Sète et puis on traverse
la France pour rejoindre mon oncle qui
vivait à l'époque à côté de Thionville
et qui nous accueille et il avait à ce
moment-là un jeune enfant parce que dans
le fond à ce moment-là il y a ce qui
compte c'est pas le soleil le lieu c'est
de se retrouver en famille et de se
retrouver aussi chez soi je pense que la
France
passer comme ça du jour au lendemain du
Maroc de la Méditerranée du soleil à la
vie moins ensoleillée de de mettre ça
doit pas être simple il y a plus
d'histoire de météo c'est pas une
histoire de météo moi
c'est beaucoup
de
qui me terre d'accueil et pour le coup
j'ai construit beaucoup de beaucoup de
souvenirs
et ce que ce dont je me souviens c'est
arrivé dans ce dans ce collège puis
d'abord puis dans puis au sein du lycée
mais surtout la rencontre avec des
hommes et des femmes qui ont permis
cette arrivée peut-être plus de manière
plus douce faut pas oublier que quand tu
arrives de l'étranger et peut-être plus
dans un moment comme ça précipité tu as
besoin de bienveillance tu as pas tout
ce qu'il faut pour pour reconstruire il
se trouve que moi ma mère à ce moment là
elle avait pas des bulletins de paye on
n'avait pas les déclarations d'impôts
qu'on demande quand on veut louer si
vous avez cette époque exactement il se
trouve que c'était un gendarme qui était
le propriétaire de la maison et qui lui
a dit écoutez madame je vous crois je je
suis sûr que vous vous serez quelqu'un
de voilà de responsable que vous allez
payer vos vos loyers ce qui a été le cas
bien sûr mais ce gendarme moi je
l'oublierai jamais il se trouve qu'il y
avait une petite fille assez à ce
moment-là qui a porté le même prénom moi
donc ça ça reste un élément marquant et
puis une autre rencontre qui était qui
était un moment fort ça a été quelques
jours après la location parce que
c'était le plus dur hein c'était
vraiment loué qui était le plus
difficile ça a été une rencontre avec
des bénévoles d'Emmaüs on n'avait pas de
déménagement et donc maman va parce
qu'il fallait tout acheter absolument
tout va au Emmaüs et pour acheter
d'abord les lits les matelas le canapé
la vaisselle on avait que que les que
les habits et une dame lui dit mais
madame enfin trouvé que c'était étonnant
d'acheter tout et elle dit mais ça enfin
vous allez bien et puis maman raconte
pas beaucoup mais un peu parce que elle
a beaucoup de d'orgueil elle ne sait pas
et puis elle n'a jamais demandé de
l'aide et cette dame lui a dit mais vous
savez la communauté Emmaüs elle est
aussi là pour aider parfois des moments
de voilà de de fracture ou il faut
redémarrer et le lendemain arrive un
camion plein de déménagement et depuis
ce jour je j'ai toujours cette
conviction profonde que la rouelle
tourne pour tout le monde mais on peut
toujours aider quelqu'un
mais oui mais parce que vous savez elle
était chef d'entreprise nous avions des
restaurants personne peut imaginer que
il y a un besoin juste de réaménage un
appartement c'était pas c'était assez
rapide c'était rude mais il faut pas
oublier que à ce moment-là on peut
croiser le parcours et le chemin de
femme engagé
de la bienveillance est-ce que vous avez
souffert aussi du racisme pas pas moi je
j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas vécu ça et
surtout ce que je dis au quotidien c'est
surtout ne tombez pas dans des dans des
situations et des positions victimaires
n'attendez pas que que ça arrive moi je
crois qu'il faut lutter contre le
racisme je suis une militante
antiraciste contre l'antisémitisme
contre l'homophobie mais il faut pas
hiérarchiser les il faut pas
hiérarchiser les discriminations il faut
lutter contre toutes donc comment quand
on lutte pour l'égalité on lutte contre
toutes les discriminations et donc il ne
faut pas être dans une situation où
quand tu as que quand tu homosexuel tu
luttes contre l'homophobie quand tu es
tous les racistes plus homophobie c'est
pareil c'est pas la discrimination dès
qu'on la dignité humaine dès qu'on
inégalité alors on est en réalité la
République et notre modèle et donc c'est
là où moi je pense qu'il faut être
extrêmement fort lutter continuer à
faire évoluer la loi comme ce que nous
faisons avec le gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron avec des condamnations plus
fortes avec le fait de former également
nos fortes Lords nos associations les
enseignants mais surtout surtout ne
jamais faire de hiérarchie entre les
discriminations les deux donc vous vous
ne faites pas d'hier les discriminations
et vous êtes aussi une mise en acharnée
pour la laïcité et contre l'islamisme
absolument moi je suis acharnée je suis
une militante pour le modèle français et
ce modèle il est universaliste ce modèle
il est il est profondément
laïc qui donne des ailes et je suis
profondément une militante de l'unité et
le pire pour moi c'est ce qui opposent
l'unité de notre pays et la laïcité
parce que la laïcité ce n'est pas la
négation de la foi c'est la liberté de
croire ou de ne pas croire de pratiquer
ou de ne pas pratiquer mais d'être d'une
certaine manière dans cette communauté
nationale et donc je je sais que je sais
à quel point cette laïcité libère elle
donne de l'énergie elle te permet d'être
ce que tu es elle ne te regarde pas
comme descendant d'une origine ce qui
coule dans ton dans ton sang elle te
regarde pas comme
l'héritier d'une confession que tu
pratiques que tu ne pratique pas elle te
regarde pas en fonction de ton
orientation sexuelle c'est la France
c'est son modèle et la laïcité c'est une
des conditions une un de ces grandes
trésors permettant ce vivre ensemble et
c'est pas un mot-valise vivre ensemble
c'est un combat de tous les jours c'est
beaucoup plus facile de s'enfermer dans
sa communauté c'est beaucoup plus facile
de d'alimenter les haines et les
jalousies c'est beaucoup plus difficile
d'aller chercher du commun on va on va
reparler de laïcité d'abord au passage
je crois que vous êtes aussi engagé dans
la réserve de la gendarmerie pourquoi et
qu'est-ce que vous a apporté qu'est-ce
que ça vous a apporté qu'est-ce que ça
vous a appris mon parcours il est il est
très simple à chaque fois que j'ai
rencontré où j'étais dans un lieu je
pense qu'on peut y apporter sa pierre
son engagement mon engagement et il a
commencé dans le monde associatif dans
dans le cercle des femmes de
Loire-Atlantique et j'ai eu la chance
d'aller faire un séminaire au alliage
EDN à l'Institut des hautes études de
défense nationale où il y a des civils
et des militaires et j'ai découvert des
hommes et des femmes qui sous le drapeau
sous notre drapeau vient s'engager pour
la France pour ses valeurs et je me suis
dit et bien à côté de chez moi je peux
aussi apporter quelque chose et j'ai
rejoint la réserve de la gendarmerie
nationale puisque moi j'ai un territoire
qui est un peu urbain avec la police
nationale et beaucoup de gendarmerie et
je me suis dit bah moi aussi je peux
apporter quelque chose et si chacun se
dit nous avons un pouvoir d'agir et nous
avons une charge une responsabilité un
devoir de participer à notre société et
bien il faut qu'on trouve qu'est-ce qui
nous passionne et moi ces hommes j'ai
énormément de respect pour ces hommes et
ces femmes ces familles qui prennent et
bien de leur des bouts de leur vie pour
participer à ce lien à cette sécurité au
quotidien vous pouvez vous parler de
laïcité il y a quelques instants quand
vous entendez Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui dit
je le cite qu'il y a dans ce pays une
haine des musulmans déguisée en laïcité
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez du dégoût
c'est du dégoût parce que il
fracture notre pays
c'est un mensonge profondément il nie le
fait que la laïcité et en réalité la
base même de l'unité de la cohésion et
donc il fait du clientélisme il alimente
ce qu'il y a de plus mauvais pourquoi
vous dites parce que il essaye de
flatter des mouvements extrémistes en
disant ça faut pas être naïf et le pire
c'est qu'en faisant ça il nie et il
jette un peu en pâture et bien des
français parfois de confession musulmane
en essayant de d'alimenter des haines et
des colères la France elle le regarde
pas ta religion elle garantit ta foi ou
ton absence de pratique ou de foi et en
faisant ça au-delà d'appuyer sur sur le
clientélisme dont il fait preuve il Nice
qui est un héritage français et alors un
autre député enfin un député France
insoumise président de la commission des
finances Éric Coquerel c'était le 19
octobre 2020 sur radio là il a comparé
la situation des musulmans dans la
France d'aujourd'hui à celle des juifs
pendant la période italienne qu'est-ce
que ça vous inspire
je condamne totalement ses propos c'est
gravissime de faire des comparaisons de
genre là
c'est l'éducation du fait historique qui
est nécessaire et vous savez embrouiller
les esprits c'est les embrigadés et donc
c'est grave et quand on a la charge et
la responsabilité de porter une écharpe
tu sais je suis député pour moi ça veut
dire beaucoup c'est un mandat de
représentation du peuple français c'est
gravissime c'est doublement plus grave
et donc ces propos bien sûr je les
condamne et
oui mais pour le coup porter de dans la
portée par un député c'est doublement
plus irresponsable parce que vous diriez
que la société notamment française est
malade de l'islamisme politique la
société française elle est minée par les
séparatistes et donc c'est pour ça que
le Président de la République dans son
discours des Mureaux à mobiliser toute
notre société par l'éducation par le
renforcement de du renseignement avec la
loi séparatisme qui renforce les
principes de la République on s'est
donné des moyens juridiques pour lutter
contre ça ce qui est certain c'est que
ces séparatisme ils alimentent ce que je
disais tout à l'heure les haines les
discriminations voir à mes pieds et je
veux dire n'oublions pas n'oublions pas
ni les situations ni les actes
terroristes ni ses coups de canifs dans
le pacte républicain au quotidien que ce
soit malheureusement parfois à l'école
ou dans la vie de tous les jours est-ce
que le risque aussi avec dans les
semaines qui viennent c'est pas la
présentation par Gérald Darmanin de son
projet de loi immigration
je pense moi je crois que aujourd'hui la
proposition de loi portait par mon
collègue Gérald Darmanin apporte des
outils et des réponses nécessaires c'est
une loi d'équilibre c'est une loi qui va
qui est discuter et qui va être discutée
au Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale qui
va être enrichi mais faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont nous sommes
un gouvernement courageux qui n'y pas
les problèmes qu'il n'y pas les chemins
pour les pour les bâtir on n'a jamais
rien mis sous le tapis et donc on se
donne les moyens dans l'exercice
démocratique et bien d'apporter des
réponses à la société française comment
vous expliquer la résurgence de
l'antisémitisme dans les quartiers
populaires provenant du jeunesse
radicalisée souvent obnubilé par la
haine d'Israël et comment en est-on
arrivé là
la faiblesse du continuum éducatif vous
savez comment un enfant un enfant
grandit il grandit parce que il est
d'abord
élevé par ses parents la responsabilité
des parents d'accompagner les
apprentissages dans un monde où il y a
énormément de réseaux sociaux de propos
haineux on sait à quel point les
algorithmes provoquent parfois des
bulles autour des enfants on sait qu'il
y a des offenses
et donc du coup la présence des parents
l'accompagnement des parents est
essentiel
ensuite après les après les parents il y
a la place de l'école des enseignants
dans l'apprentissage des faits
historiques la place de la science la
place de l'éducation aux médias l'esprit
critique et puis enfin nous avons besoin
de finalement de l'engagement de tous
ceux qui accompagnent et qui encadent
les enfants je pense aux animateurs au
monde associatif et si il n'y a pas une
solidarité forte entre tous ces maillons
de cette chaîne s'il y en a une qui est
défaillante alors malheureusement les
plus vulnérables c'est à dire les
enfants les adolescents et bien tombent
entre les mains des discours les plus
haineux et donc que ce soit des discours
antisémites racistes homophobe ou
parfois malheureusement absolument
séparatiste pour lutter contre ça nous
avons besoin que l'ensemble des adultes
autour soit solide et revenir aux
essentiels repère historiques la valeur
des mots la valeur des comparaisons et
c'est aussi pour ça que tout à l'heure
je condamné les propos du Sénat du
député Coquerel parce que ce mélange
cette volonté d'allumer d'allumer des
haines d'alimenter d'alimenter des
colères et puis surtout de pervertir les
esprits ne crée que le pire
malheureusement vous avez parlé donc de
la famille de l'éducation de des écoles
de l'école il y a aussi la presse au
passage quand vous constatez cette
semaine que le rappeur made in un
compagnon de route des islamistes et des
antisémites étant une debdomadaire
politique un hebdomadaire proche de la
France insoumise pour incarner
l'opposition la réforme des retraites
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
nous sommes dans un état de droit je
crois qu'il a été plus d'une fois
condamné
il a commencé par apparaître sur les
réseaux sociaux portant un t-shirt ciglé
du mot jihad avec un sabre à côté il
avait aussi la quenelle antisémite de
Dieudonné il s'est affiché sur les
réseaux sociaux en faisant cette
quenelle il s'est affiché avec
l'indigéniste antisémitorielle avec
Tariq Ramadan ou aussi avec Kimi Seba
puis on en a d'autres qu'on a dépend de
ces métiers voilà qui est made in vous
avez fait le portrait pour moi d'un
homme qui n'est certainement pas un rôle
modèle ça pour le coup c'est très clair
mais comme je vous disais moi je crois
les a de droit et comme vous l'avez
rappelé il a été condamné maintenant la
presse dans notre pays est libre il y a
des lignes éditoriales et c'est pour ça
que l'éducation médias est absolument
essentielle il faut permettre aux gens
aux enfants aux jeunes d'avoir la
compréhension de ces lignes éditoriales
pour pouvoir aussi et bien avoir
l'esprit critique nécessaire et
comprendre que tout n'est pas à prendre
bien comme ça vient et au contraire de
creuser de déb et surtout de d'aller
chercher des informations
complémentaires et c'est le fruit de
notre c'est l'engagement de la politique
jeunesse que je mène aujourd'hui que ce
soit dans le cadre de la formation des
animateurs dans le cadre du BAFA ou que
ce soit ce qu'on fait dans le temps
extrascolaire moi mon enjeu le plus
grand c'est de donner les moyens aux
jeunes de s'émanciper d'être des esprits
libres des esprits qui critiquent qui
vont chercher la contradiction qui vont
chercher les sources pas qui tombent
dans du de l'idéologie servie quasiment
au drive est-ce qu'il faut considérer
que le choix éditorial de politesse avec
donc la saït une de offerte à Médine
participe des dérives de la gauche
mélenchoniste ce qui est certain c'est
que la ligne éditoriale pour le coup
d'un certain nombre de presse et
économies et les proximités politiques
aussi pour le coup ce qui est malheureux
c'est que moi je crois que notre
jeunesse est la jeunesse de France a
besoin de rôle modèle elle a besoin
d'énergie elle a besoin d'hommes et de
femmes qui font qui leur donne des ailes
pas qui leur brise leurs espoirs et les
discours victimaires mortifères brise
les espoirs de notre jeunesse donc dans
le fond il n'y a pas de projet il n'y a
aucun projet en ayant finalement ses
choix là moi ma mission c'est au
contraire d'aiguiser les esprits alors
votre mission justement vous êtes ce
côté à la jeunesse et aussi du service
national universel est-ce que vous voyez
est-ce qu'il faut voir la main de la
France insoumise derrière la
mobilisation émaillée de violence des
lycéens étudiants jeudi dans les rues de
Paris mais aussi de Nantes de Marseille
contre la réforme des retraites et
l'utilisation par le gouvernement du
49-3 vous savez si je reviens sur la
réforme des retraites c'est une réforme
qui est nécessaire qui est nécessaire
qui demande un effort aux français bien
sûr mais il faut rappeler que elle a été
énormément débattue à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat quel a été votée en
commission mixparitaire que l'avait voté
par les sénateurs par deux fois mais qui
a souhaité le chaos qui a amené le chaos
la France insoumise la France insoumise
dans le débat parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale ils ont souhaité
le chaos par de l'Obs parlementaire ils
appellent un frein de la loi ils ont ils
n'ont pas permis le débat serein alors
même que pendant des mois le ministre du
Travail la première ministre ont
consulté d'abord les organisations
syndicales les groupes politiques les
représentants des différentes des
différents groupes également
parlementaires et dans le fond ce qui ne
font que bâtir le chaos c'est la France
insoumise
ne propose jamais rien à bâtir ne font
que détruire et je crois que
historiquement c'est dans leur idéologie
et donc c'est d'avoir ADN le fait de
détruire le fait de créer le chaos de
créer l'opposition de la formation
totalement et de Jean-Luc Mélenchon moi
j'en ai la conviction et par rapport à
la violence donc la violence des
manifestants de jeudi soir vous savez la
violence n'a jamais été une forme
d'expression
je suis pas pour le coup Madame Irma
pour pour dire c'est la main de c'est la
main de qui mais ce qui est certain
c'est quand vous avez un mouvement
politique ou des élus qui appellent à la
violence c'est grave il a légitime pas
grave moi je n'ai je ne considérais
jamais que la violence est un mode
d'expression au contraire moi j'ai salué
le fait que les manifestations du début
ont été accompagnées par les mouvements
syndicaux parce que j'étais moi-même
responsable et bien sûr j'ai débattu
j'ai signé des accords j'ai construit
des points de consensus je viens d'une
histoire et d'une histoire syndicale
d'une histoire de dialogue de consensus
d'un syndicat un syndicat qui m'était
effectivement un chrétien dans son dans
ses racines quand il y a eu la scission
entre la CFDT et la CFC pour faire la
minute d'histoire mais pour moi elle
était un peu il était important ce mon
choix était vers cette organisation
syndicale parce que c'était une
organisation qui bâtissait qui crée des
liens et surtout qui mettaient aussi la
famille au cœur des échanges et donc
elle prenait en considération bien sûr
la vie du salarié bien sûr mais aussi et
les conséquences que ça peut avoir sur
ses enfants l'équilibre entre les femmes
et les hommes l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes l'équilibre sur le temps
personnel et le temps professionnel et
je trouvais que quand on est un salarié
quand on est un travailleur qu'on est un
parent on n'est pas trois personnes on
est là même et c'est bien d'apporter
cette lecture
nous allons trouver une porte de sortie
par la force
on n'a jamais jamais rien bâti sur la
violence ou l'opposition ou le fait de
détruire comment comment vous voulez
comment dire
des choses je dis qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
vendredi pardon qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
j'encourage les manifestations
spontanées dans tout le pays un
responsable politique qui a eu qui a eu
des qui a eu des mandats des mandats
électoraux la représentation la charge
qui voulait en plus être qui était
candidat à l'élection présidentielle qui
appelle effectivement à la chanlie et
qui appelle surtout à ne pas respecter
la loi il respecte à ne il appelle à ne
pas respecter notre État de droit c'est
ça le plus grave c'est
une personnalité politique
pas vraiment démocratique et les filles
c'est un parti séditieux vous savez moi
ce sont mes adversaires politiques moi
je pour le coup je les combats il y a un
certain nombre d'entre eux qui sont
aujourd'hui sur les bancs à l'Assemblée
nationale qui sont du coup légitimes
puisque élu et lui démocratiquement moi
je viens du Mouvement Démocrate un parti
qui porte dans son nom le mot démocratie
et qui tient assez qui tient à ça mais
un parti qui appelle un homme qui
appelle à la violence qui appelle au non
respect bah aujourd'hui quand on prend
ses propos il appelle à ne pas respecter
la loi et on peut pas on peut pas avoir
été législateur être responsable d'un
mouvement politique et ne pas appeler à
respecter les règles qui sont les règles
de notre État de droit ça veut dire que
et les filles et Mélenchon mais de lui
sur le feu ben je crois que dans ce leur
dans leur ADN effectivement
l'embrasement fait partie de leur
méthode créer du chaos créer un espace
ceux qui ne permet pas le dialogue mais
c'est pour ça que il ne faut pas tomber
dans le piège nous notre majorité
n'a jamais jamais quitté la table des
négociations ni avec les organisations
syndicales ni avec les autres mouvements
d'ailleurs la réforme des retraites a
été énormément améliorée le texte qui a
été qui a été présenté à la commission
mix paritaire il a été enrichi par les
parties
j'entends mais parce que c'est mais oui
mais ça a été ça a été débattu ce n'est
pas passé l'assemblée parce que ce n'est
parce que la news n'a pas souhaité
permettre ça ils ont fait de
l'obstruction mais dans le fond les
rythmes
notre majorité les modem les élus MoDem
les élus horizons les élus de
renaissance ont apporté un certain
nombre d'avancées je pense aux carrières
longues je pense au un certain nombre la
clause de revoyure pour les modem je
pense bien sûr à la au rendez-vous
médical à 45 ans et à 60 ans il a eu
énormément d'avancé mais
ça a été voté d'abord par le Sénat et
puis en commission
c'est un problème de communication de
stratégie politique quoi vous savez où
ce n'est pas l'intérêt personnel c'est
une réforme ou c'est l'intérêt de la
France qui prime je vais vous donner
juste un exemple quand vous prenez la
responsabilité et la charge de faire
porter nos retraites nos retraites sur
nos enfants aujourd'hui ça veut dire que
demain ils auront à payer la leur mais
aussi celle la dette qu'on leur a
transmise et ça ce n'est pas acceptable
et donc oui parfois c'est nécessaire et
je crois que c'est la grandeur de là de
la vie politique et c'est la
responsabilité du Président de la
République que de faire passer l'intérêt
l'intérêt national l'intérêt supérieur
de la nation au dessus des intérêts
parfois et bien des intérêts individuels
et ça a été des opportunistes politiques
ça ça a été le comportement d'une partie
et bien des opposants pour revenir aux
violences de jeudi soir est-ce qu'on est
passé à une autre étape plus violente de
la contestation et ce qui a un risque de
radiquer les escients de Gilles
ionisation de la contestation
d'opposition à la réforme des retraites
est-ce que le 49-3 n'a pas mis le feu au
pays le 49 le 49.3 est un outil
démocratique constitution est-ce qu'il a
mis le feu au pays
pourquoi pourquoi il y avait 49
,3 une proposition nups à l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas permis le débat et le
vote en première lecture mais ce mais ce
texte a été débattu pendant des dizaines
d'heures il a été voté il a été revoté
et puis j'ai envie de vous dire chacun
pour apprendre ses responsabilités il y
aura certainement des motions de censure
le débat aura lieu au début de semaine
exactement et chacun devra prendre ses
responsabilités mais ce qui est certain
c'est que c'est une réforme qui a été
améliorée débattue par les
parlementaires qui doit nous permettre
et bien de ne pas baisser les pensions
de retraite et de permettre une
revalorisation des plus précaires mais
aussi la réalité c'est ça de ne pas
augmenter les impôts parce que ceux qui
payent en général l'augmentation des
impôts et bien c'est les classes
moyennes et pour ça nous nous refusons à
ça la question qu'on se pose de Peugeot
du soir est-ce que le 49 3 n'a pas mis
le feu au pays le 49,3 c'est une c'est
un outil c'est un outil constitutionnel
totalement légitime et encore une fois
avant le 49-3 il y a eu plusieurs bottes
qui ont eu lieu au Sénat en commission
mix paritaire il y a eu des votes qui
ont validé à plus deux fois contexte ce
n'est pas le texte du Gouvernement qui a
été présenté ça a été le texte enrichi
par les deux assemblées et demain il y
aura une motion de censure sur lequel
chacun pourra s'exprimer et prendre ses
responsabilités
responsable du blocage ce sont les
hommes et les femmes qui ont fait de
l'obstruction parlementaire et ça a été
la nuit épaisse à l'Assemblée nationale
qui n'a pas permis le débat le vote
alors même que la majorité souhaitait
voter la majorité souhaitait mettre en
oeuvre et du coup assumer le vote
jusqu'au bout puisqu'ils ont enrichi ce
texte maintenant la responsabilité qui
est la nôtre celle évidemment du
gouvernement de la première ministre et
du président de la République c'est de
garantir et bien une réforme nécessaire
enrichie mais nécessaire dans l'intérêt
de la France même si malheureusement et
bien c'est une réforme qui demande de
l'effort mais un effort juste et je
crois que c'est l'essentiel qu'est-ce
que vous attendez courageux pour faire
cette réforme ce que vous attendez du
débat de censure de demain est-ce que le
gouvernement peut tomber est-ce
qu'Elisabeth borne ne sort pas affaibli
de la séquence
l'essentiel c'est de protéger notre
système par répartition et ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire ne pas laisser les
plus précaires ne pas avoir de retraite
parce que le modèle est un modèle autre
par capitalisation ou autre c'est
protéger les plus petites retraites
parce que nous sommes dans une période
inflationniste et ne pas laisser des
hommes et des femmes qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie être dans des toutes
petites pensions c'est permettre de
corriger aujourd'hui malheureusement les
inégalités de notre marché du travail
mais surtout surtout de ne pas faire
peser aujourd'hui le modèle le modèle de
la retraite par répartition sur nos
enfants parce que aujourd'hui on
emprunte pour payer les retraites et si
demain on veut qu'ils aient une retraite
eux et bien il faut faire cette réforme
courageuse
borne ne sort pas affaiblis de cette
séquence la première ministre Elisabeth
borne comme l'ensemble du gouvernement a
beaucoup travaillé a beaucoup débattu
construit bâti moi je vois une première
ministre dont je suis fier qui a
énormément
mobilisé et construit cette majorité
nécessaire mais surtout elle a pris avec
beaucoup de courage le choix est bien de
poser notre une responsabilité notre
responsabilité devant et bien les
assembler pour une réforme nécessaire
encore une fois celle des retraites pour
garantir que les pensions augmentent et
garantir qu'on puisse les payer dedans
il va falloir rebondir ça passe par quoi
par un remaniement un remaniement
d'ampleur ou par de nouvelles réformes
vous savez je pense que quand on
appartient à bien un gouvernement
courageux qui ne choisit pas
l'opportunisme politique ou les intérêts
personnels ou même la popularité mais
l'intérêt des Français et bien on
continue à réformer et bien la santé
l'hôpital bien sûr la mère des batailles
c'est l'école c'est ce qui élève les
esprits c'est ce qui garantit l'égalité
des chances c'est ce qui lutte contre
les contre les fractures et les n c'est
ce qui permettra demain de lutter contre
l'abstention c'est ce qui permettra
demain d'avoir un pays beaucoup plus uni
mais surtout un pays qui se fait
confiance et qui n'est pas des
fétichiste vous êtes plus à l'aise en
tant que ministre
sous la responsabilité du Jean-Michel
Blanquer ou de PAP and Jerry vous savez
moi je suis une ministre en charge de la
jeunesse et du service national qui a eu
la chance sous Jean-Michel Blanquer et
vient de porter évidemment les combats
qui étaient les nôtres et aujourd'hui
avec papédia et de construire le service
national universel avec également
Sébastien Lecornu puisque j'ai la sens
d'avoir une double une double entrée
celle de l'éducation nationale parce que
je travaille avec les enseignants et les
associations d'expression populaire et
avec les armées pour construire le
service national
universels des réformes à venir celles
qui vous concerne c'est-à-dire c'est on
va en parler c'est la mise en place du
service national universel sur le temps
scolaire comment ça va se faire comment
ça va marcher et ça va être sur effectif
à partir de quand c'est le service
national aujourd'hui nous le faisons
parce que on ne peut pas faire des
constats pendant des mois pendant des
années en disant regardez notre jeunesse
et les fracturée regardez notre jeunesse
elle vit dans des situations pas égales
quand on est en territoire rural ou en
territoire urbain on regarde on constate
et on rien de très massif moi mon enjeu
pendant ces trois dernières années ça a
été de porter des politiques jeunesse de
regarder la jeunesse dans sa diversité
et surtout d'aller bâtir ce commun ce
temps qui n'existe nulle part ailleurs
en complémentarité de l'école et en
complémentarité de l'engagement
associatif pour qu'un jeune de trappe
puisse rencontrer un jeune Nantais et un
jeune du ciel du 7e arrondissement de
Paris et un jeune de Guéret et bien il
n'y a pas de moment il n'y a pas de lieu
et dans le fond
je vous interrompre 30 secondes est-ce
qu'à travers le service national
universel vous n'êtes pas en train de
réparer quelque part les conséquences de
la suppression du service national le
service national a vocation a créé du
commun de créer de l'unité ce n'est pas
le service militaire ce n'est pas non
plus le ce n'est pas non plus une
colonie de vacances c'est un temps
nouveau qui se construit sur le meilleur
de l'école le meilleur de l'école sur le
meilleur de l'éducation associative
populaire et le meilleur de l'esprit et
de nos armées pourquoi parce que dans le
fond ce sont 15 jours dans lesquels ils
sortent de leur départ
en fait le service est universel quelque
chose de nouveau alors on a l'habitude
de comparer avec ce qu'on connaît mais
pas là on sort de son département on
arrive dans un centre souvent des
centres de vacances et pendant 15 jours
et bien on est entouré de jeunes filles
et jeunes garçons qui entre 15 et 17 ans
qu'on ne connaît pas qui ne viennent pas
des mêmes établissements scolaires on
est en uniforme on a des rituels
républicains on a surtout la rencontre
avec la République parce que dans le
fond on découvre nos institutions nos
collectivités ont on les vain de drapeau
le matin on chante une Marseillaise
ensemble mais on a accès à des médecins
oh pas du tout ce n'est absolument pas
l'armée dans le sens où il n'y a aucun
maniement aux armes l'objectif du Séni
c'est de de créer un accélérateur de
confiance et donc un accélérateur de de
d'égalité des chances on présente des
chances d'intégration bien sûr de
construction de notre identité nationale
commune de donner ce patrimoine là à
chacun de ces jeunes de lui donner
confiance en lui et en son pays c'est la
France de la confiance dans sa jeunesse
et demain une France Forte une France
unie c'est une France où sa jeunesse
elle prend pleinement sa part et nous on
veut pas bâtir une chanson cette
jeunesse alors on lui donne les moyens
et bien de d'être engagé dans le monde
associatif dans le monde militaire
puisque propose un certain nombre
d'engagement après volontaire sur le
monde militaire après 18 ans bien sûr ou
après dans
un engagement militaire au sein de nos
réserves qui se pose service national
universel obligatoire ou pas le
président de la République va avoir
l'occasion de s'exprimer bientôt
un maximum de jeunes de le faire ça va
faire plus de trois ans que nous le
faisons moi quand j'ai commencé il y
avait 2000 jeunes qui faisaient le SMU
aujourd'hui on a plus de 50000 des
jeunes filles et des jeunes garçons qui
ne se seraient jamais croisés
le débat sera ouvert un débat
parlementaire sera ouvert je souhaite
que ça soit utile au maximum des jeunes
quel que soit le chemin obligatoire oh
le maximum des jeunes pour ne pas créer
des inégalités ni de classe sociale ni
de territoire c'est un investissement
aujourd'hui c'est 140 millions pour plus
de 50 000 jeunes mais dans le fond c'est
le plus bel investissement qu'on puisse
faire parce que celui-là celui-là on le
fait dans notre jeunesse et cette
politique jeunesse très large avec
évidemment je pense très largement aux
autres formes d'engagement au BAFA qu'on
peut célébrer parce que ça repart ça
repart l'engagement dans nos classes
défense dans l'engagement c'est ce qui
donne le sel de notre modèle pourtant
pourtant cette annonce d'un service
stationnaire obligatoire universel ça
c'est à la ça crée ça a lancé des
polémiques notamment par de lancer par
elephi qui vous accuse de mettre au
palagenèse à travers un dispositif
digestif coûteux qui ne remplit aucun
objectif légitime en termes de défense
d'éducation d'insertion le but de député
élevé Benjamin Lucas est considéré il a
dit à l'assemblée que la République ne
s'enchaînait pas coup de pompe de défilé
grotesque ou en portant des casquettes
ridicules et puis aussi des inquiétudes
chez les syndicats notamment le stress
s'est fait su qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez
totalement caricature totalement le
dispositif et je les invite d'ailleurs à
aller voir et à écouter les témoignages
de ces jeunes mais je veux dire le plus
le plus condamnable c'est que il se
moque de jeunes garçons et jeunes filles
qui ont qu'un 16 ans qui prennent 15
jours de leur temps pour se former et
bien sûr ils se moquent deux ils se
moque de leur engagement ils se moque du
fait que ces jeunes sont partis
découvrir l'autre qu'ils ont appris les
gestes qui sauvent qui ont ils ont été
fermés en cas de catastrophe naturelle
c'est honteux c'est idéologiquement
honteux le débat un jour arrivera au
sein de nos assemblées et à ce moment-là
ils devront assumer le fait que il ne
souhaite pas investir dans la jeunesse
qu'il souhaite les priver et finalement
d'égalité d'engagement qu'il souhaite
les priver de l'apprentissage de la
citoyenne
qui qui peut être notamment la perte de
deux semaines de cours ainsi et les
difficultés organisées à ces jours à
poser qu'est-ce que vous répondez
l'organisation des séjours aujourd'hui
elle est portée par mon administration
et avec des associations un certain
nombre d'associations d'éducation
populaire moi je le je leur dis
participer à la construction regardez à
quel point ça ça permet à des jeunes de
découvrir de grandir d'avoir confiance
en eux et surtout demain de bâtir une
société plus unie ça peut pas dire que
les réformes de l'école ne doivent pas
continuer le SNU ne résoudra pas tous
les mots de notre société parce que par
contre ce qui est certain c'est que
c'est peut-être un temps fort un temps
fort d'unité nationale on peut pas
passer notre temps à dire que notre
société est fragmenté qu'elle est
archipelisée et qu'on investisse pas
dans ce qui permet de créer de l'unité à
ceux qui disent ça va embraser la
jeunesse pas du tout il suffit de
regarder les jeunes qui ont fait le SMU
9 jeunes sur 10 qui ont fait le service
national sont extrêmement satisfaits
très satisfaits de ce projet maintenant
j'ai envie de vous dire ceux qui vont
chercher la polémique et bien en réalité
ne veulent pas donner des des de
l'énergie des aides ils ont pas
confiance en la jeunesse moi ce que je
vois c'est une jeunesse qui doit vivre
plein de défis ces défis sont multiples
la planète le temps la transformation
environnementale la question du de la
dislocation du séparatisme la
transformation d'une escamène le
numérique le fait que les 10 dans les
produits prochaines années les métiers
que de la moitié où ils le connaissent
pas comment on les aide comment
finalement on n'est pas dans une
reproduction sociale et bien ceux qui ne
que veulent lutter contre ça ceux qui
veulent vraiment créer recréer cette
escalier social français et bien ils
investissent en réalité ils investissent
dans la jeunesse et au plus haut point
alors certains proposent une autre
solution l'idée d'une allocation
jeunesse à tous ceux qui sont dans la
possibilité de travailler et qui suit
des études qui se trouvent en formation
est-ce que c'est d'actualité
à la pauvreté ce que nous avons fait
c'est le contrat d'engagement jeune pour
des jeunes qui sont dans des difficultés
mais tu verse une aide financière bien
sûr parce que tu en as besoin et que
notre pays il sonore à aider ceux qui
sont en situation difficile mais quand
tu as entre 16 ans et 25 ans c'est à
dire avant l'âge d'avoir le RSA tu as
nous avons la responsabilité en tant que
grand pays de lui donner les moyens de
trouver une formation un emploi de
résoudre parfois des difficultés
sociales d'addiction de santé ça
s'appelle le contrat d'engagement jeune
aujourd'hui dans notre pays il y a des
droits il y a des devoirs notre devoirs
c'est d'accompagner la jeunesse de lui
donner les moyens de s'en sortir pas de
la condamner dans des trappes et des
choses trappes à pauvreté et pourtant
une partie de la jeunesse et a vécu
comme
ce vie pardon comme la génération
sacrifiée de la crise sanitaire et
aujourd'hui de la réforme des retraites
est-ce que vous comprenez ça et est-ce
que c'est aussi votre sentiment vous
savez déjà ceux qui parlent de la
jeunesse il se trompent ils se mettent
le doigt dans l’œil il y en a pas une
c'est vrai on peut à 18 ans et bien on
peut être parent on peut être jeune
rural gene urbain on peut être jeune en
train de faire des études en réalité il
y a des jeunesse donc déjà arrêtons de
créer une homogène elle est diverse et
donc si on est honnête et bien on
regarde chacune d'entre elles moi je
vois des jeunes qui travaillent qui
essaient de s'en sortir qui se
mobilisent qui s'engage dans les assauts
je vois des jeunes plus en difficulté
parce que parfois c'est ils ont pas
l'aide familiale permettant de voilà de
gagner de conquérir le monde moi je veux
une jeunesse audacieuse ambitieuse qui a
foi en la République à foi en la France
et pour ça et bien il faut créer des
rencontres et donc quand je quand
j'entends ça je leur dis mais un vous
vous trompez de
la force qu'on mettra dans notre
jeunesse c'est de le permettre et bien
de répondre à tous les défis qu'il
attendent ça veut dire quoi renforcer
l'école renforcer le travail aller
chercher le plein d'emploi on a le taux
de chômage le plus bas des 40 dernières
années et c'est grâce à des réformes que
ce gouvernement a fait et c'est comme ça
que Françoise que la jeunesse ne lâche
pas prise bien sûr parce que son avenir
aujourd'hui il dépend des de mesures
courageux ce qu'il faut faire et
peut-être pas populaire c'est vrai mais
quand on fait la réforme des retraites
et bien on garantit entre autres le
modèle de la retraite par répartition
c'est ça veut dire un modèle de
solidarité intégration ça veut dire
qu'il faut accompagner nos aînés et
accompagner nos plus jeunes pour qu'ils
puissent et bien tenir cette unité là
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation bonne fin de journée
sur radiologie à dimanche prochain merci
merci à vous et bon dimanche